it's now time to welcome in our friend
from NBC Sports his football morning in
America column is must read there's so
much to talk about with Peter King I uh
welcome Peter into the uh the rich aen
show here exclusively now on peacock how
are you
Peter good morning out west R Eisen good
afternoon back East yeah you bet so uh I
will give you the floor on somebody
who's got his ear to the ground finger
on the pulse every other way to put it
what is the story in the NFL this very
morning uh with two games left in week
four Peter King what is
it oh I
suppose uh you know the antenna are up
about Co and about how serious it could
uh you know what it could mean with the
uh you know to play a full season to
play an ontime season I think that's
probably even though you know there's
one really good game tonight and there's
one really good other team playing
tonight uh and it certainly will be you
know a good football
night I just think you know you know
Rich we you know I got up this morning
very early uh for me anyway on Monday uh
because I wanted to find out what if
anything was uh what was going on with
the
Patriots and when I woke up and followed
them during the morning and was uh
making a couple of calls about it you
know I look on Twitter and I see on WBZ
in Boston it's like the white Ford
Bronco Chase yeah I know you you've got
a helicopter over the Patriots five team
buses going to Logan
Airport it's just I don't mean to say
what have we come to in this country
that we're covering second by second a
team going to the airport to make sure a
football game gets played tonight but
there's a little bit of weirdness to it
all well I mean obviously 2020 is is off
the off the rails as we know uh Peter
but I I I guess again um there is no
greater Escape in our country than
National Football League football when
fantasy leagues uh are are up and
running for casual sports fans and so on
and so forth when you say the antenna
are up um good news is that the Titans
have tested negative for the first time
throughout the organization
today uh do we know what's ha what
happened there and what what's been
gleaned from it to potentially avoid uh
another such situation happening because
it appears that the bullet was dodged
with the Titans Crossing streams with
the Vikings uh on that field on Sunday
yeah um is there anything that's been
gleaned about the what happened there
about what can be done here interesting
you mention that rich I think the good
news for the NFL I think is that and I
was explaining this to a member of the
um well I'll just say I was explaining
it to someone who's going to be on the
field uh tonight in Kansas
City um who told me that there are a lot
of
worried
employees uh in his building about Co
and uh and the spread of Co and I said
well you know there's one one thing I
would say is and and obviously this is
anecdotal but you know does if if you're
worried about football
spreading
covid-19 uh and I'm not saying that it
doesn't but when the Tennessee Titans
played
Minnesota wouldn't you think that some
members of the Minnesota Vikings either
team or staff or something would have
been infected if uh a football game on
the field were a super spreader
event um and I'm not saying that it
isn't it could be but to me I think one
of the issues that everybody was worried
about is that once guys get their hands
on each other and sweat on each other
and and are in close
proximity uh you know Co can spread but
it didn't at least in that particular
case um said that I mean the tennessy
Titans uh are being obviously being
investigated by both the league and the
NFL pa uh and again I'm not there I
don't know what happened you know I read
uh yesterday what Ian Rapaport and Tom
pisera reported uh that uh there are
some concerns about maybe uh some LAX
protocols uh you know inside the Titans
so we'll see if that you know comes to
fruition or uh see if that's accurate
and but whatever it is I think the one
thing I mean I talked to Kevin stansky
last night and one of the things he told
me you know he he obviously was I'm not
saying jovial he's not a particularly
jovial guy but he obviously was happy to
relay some stories from the game and
everything he got dead
serious when I asked him about uh about
covid and about their protocols and and
and all that other stuff and and and he
said you know we're taking it incredibly
seriously and because we want them he
said we want to play football and I
think that is a great message to be
learned from what happened in Tennessee
and now obviously the Titans are going
to have to have two or three days at
least uh with all negative uh tests to
be able to get back in their building
and to be assured that they're going to
be able to play a football game uh you
know this weekend against Buffalo Peter
King here on the rich oen show so you
did speak to Kevin stefansky the coach
of the Cleveland Browns who have now won
three in a row for the first time in
forever to use the Frozen song phrase
right there so how real are the Browns
do you think
Peter um well I hesitate and jumping on
any Browns bandwagon because every time
you do that at least in my lifetime uh
you end up getting slapped in the face
so
um and and I but I think there's a
couple of different things now okay they
have a truly dominant defensive player
in Miles Garrett
I
mean I would I would just say that
there's very little question that Aaron
Donald is the best defensive player in
football and probably the best player in
football um but if that's the case and
there's no shame in saying that Miles
Garrett is number two um and I believe
he is uh three consecutive games now
with a strip sack uh um you he's so so
hard to
block so I mean there's there's an
Unstoppable force on defense and on
offense even with the you know the
injury now to Nick chub which apparently
is going to keep him out for
sometime um the even with the injury to
Nick chub I think that they have an
excellent one of the differences with
with Cleveland now rich is that they
have some depth on their their depth
chart you know I don't know if you watch
much of the game yesterday but I watched
almost every snap of that game and this
guy the earnest Johnson is a heck of a
running back sure is from the same uh
town uh as uh as Eder and James in
Florida IM M Florida and man he is hard
to bring down and he's quick and I mean
I I just I think that they have a lot of
things
to make it difficult to play against in
my opinion which is again a great
guarded way to say the Browns may be for
real I should be I was just joking um
about the First Time Forever by the way
I looked it up they they did win three
in a row last year uh at some point and
now here they uh go visit
Indianapolis um which just put the
absolute bang thing on Nick Foles
yesterday uh what do the Bears do right
now Peter what's going on there I think
we all thought the Bears were not quite
as good as three and 0 anybody who would
watch them play you know obviously
thought they weren't three and 0 a
three- and 0 caliber team but having
said that uh you know they've they've
got a good
defense and an occasionally high-powered
offense
occasionally and um and I would just I'd
stick with fos let him play for a month
and then let's see where you are and if
he's not doing it if he is uh as
ineffective as he was yesterday then you
have to decide whether you're giving
Mitchell tuisy one last chance football
morning in America columnist Peter King
here uh on the Rich Eisen show what else
did you glean overnight but uh you can
tell my viewership listenership right
here just to open the floor up to you
about what you learned last night or
today
couple of couple of teams that I think
are entering a bit of a Twilight Zone
one of them is
Houston um you know there's no question
even though Bill O'Brien has won four
division titles in six years that uh the
fans certainly are restless in Houston
and I think that if there were if there
were full crowds uh at games I think
yesterday the crowd would have treated
the Texans and particularly Bill O'Brien
uh you know very
disrespectfully um I you know look we
know what happened in Houston uh Bill
O'Brien felt he absolutely positively
needed a left tackle and so then he had
to overpay for laramy tunel and he felt
this year like there's no way I'm G to
be able to
resign uh because I'm not paying him 23
million a year DeAndre Hopkins so he did
what he thought he he made what he
thought was the best deal he could make
for DeAndre
Hopkins I don't really have nearly as
much of a problem by the way with the
tonsil trade because left tackles are so
hard to find I have a problem with not
scouring every team in the league now it
could be that here Jack easterby made a
phone call to every team about DeAndre
Johnson I don't know that but they
really didn't get very much for him and
uh so that's going to have to be Cal
McNair is going to have to decide
whether uh obrian Easter be one or both
um is going to be in trouble at the end
of the year I the one other thing I I
think that sort of sticks out after
yesterday uh you know in terms of a game
uh
Focus Rich this Joe burrow yeah he's not
afraid of any anything yeah he hangs in
there and look you're not going to
Canton by beating the Jacksonville
Jaguars in
2020 but Joe burrow is has such good
feel such good presence I mean just
imagine right now you know you're either
a Bengals fan or a Chargers fan and
those aren't the two biggest fan bases
in the United States but you're pretty
good you're in pretty good shape at
quarterback right now for the future you
drafted very well at 1 and six uh you
know in the draft last April so I guess
again you were so spot on about burrow
he's so fun to watch he then tweets out
winning his fun which is a which is fun
I mean everything about him is fun and
and you see how he is in command in a
way that you wouldn't expec in maybe a
rookie four games in and Justin Herbert
dropped a 60 yard dime on uh on the
Bucks defense with people in his grill
yesterday and and and and he has
definitely acquitted himself very well
almost beat the defending World Champs
when he found out but at the coin toss
um so it begs the qu that he was going
to start so it begs the question as the
Dolphins settled for field goal after
field goal yesterday and I understand
that he was sick thank goodness not due
to covid throughout the the last week
when do you think we might uh see two a
time in Min and Miami with all ultimate
respect to Ryan Fitzpatrick who uh is
playing so well and has uh the locker
room um at his you know lifting him up
literally figuratively but when do you
think two a time might hit in
Miami I don't think it's going to be
long rich but um you know I I I think
that uh Brian Flores is one of those
coaches who very much understands that
this
season is mostly about the future for
the Miami
Dolphins and the most important thing is
you come out of
2020 able to contend on opening Day
2021 for an AFC Championship that's what
you that's what this year is about and
at least in my opinion he's got to feel
now at least right now deep down that
Ryan
Fitzpatrick uh is the guy who's going to
give him the best chance let's say this
week of to win in San Francisco now is
that fair is it right I don't know but
uh I don't think it'll be long this week
next week the week after that he makes
the change Fitzpatrick knows he's a
fatalist um you know he told me on my
podcast last last week that basically
I mean in these exact words I know that
I'm keeping the seat warm for him right
so you're not going to have any issue
with Ryan Fitzpatrick grousing when he's
called into the office and told by Brian
Flor say we're playing the
kid Peter King here a few more minutes
left with the the football morning in
America columnist football night in
America contributor um and NBC Sports
colleague here on the Rich Eisen show
interesting how you mention mentioned
earlier Peter that it might make things
more difficult for Bill O'Brien if there
were fans in the stands usually when
coaches get got midseason it's because
ownership hears the fans in the stands
looks around and sees fewer fans in the
stands and in order to I guess cauterize
that fires the coach as we know there
are no fans in the stands uh except in a
few spots and even when they are there
uh they're not filling up a stadium I'm
just wondering if that might actually
prevent coaches from getting got
midseason like the Jets who have never
fired a coach in the middle Seas that's
a great question it allows an owner to
be more patient you know if you're not
getting the chance CH ants in the
stadium during the game that's one less
reason to fire a guy you really really
like and you know so look I don't know
what's what's going to happen you know I
think you and I both probably get the
feeling that we certainly get the
feeling that Adam gase is gone and we
get the feeling that Dan Quinn unless
they have a you know an absolute uh
miracle in Atlanta uh that he's going to
be going and then you start to get to
the next level you know then you start
to think about Bill O'Brien and and you
know when you think about Bill O'Brien
you think about Matt
Patricia you know you think basically
that over the last three months of this
season they need to do pretty much a 180
from where they are right now and I
think those are the four coaches that
kind of lead the parade of guys who were
going to be in the most trouble at the
end of the year and then you just wonder
in each particular case will there be a
full house cleaning now I doubt that
there's going to be a full house
cleaning with the Jets nor do I think
there should be I think that Joe Douglas
should be giving a full fair chance uh
to rebuild this team I I know from
talking to people around the league and
and from knowing general managers that
this is a highly highly respected guy uh
who by the way has uh you know at the
end of this year is going to have four
years and about
12 or 133 million left on his contract
so be careful what you wish for in
saying that you know he should be gone
but I do think that that in all these
other places that there's a very good
chance that GM is in trouble too and
then you know Matt Patricia there's a
lot of people today um certainly in
Detroit who took issue with him saying
after they blew another game in which
they led by double digits um taking on a
Saints team that again I I mean you want
to talk about Shawn pyton said he was
proud of his team and he damn well
should be I mean where they didn't you
know they thought do we have coid or do
we not and then they had always go to
sleep and sleep on that and then wake up
and and play a game on the road and that
might be the reason why they fell down
by two touchdowns but Breeze is winging
around I just want to place the Saints
aside I'm sure you again heard the the
comment that Matt Patricia said that he
didn't have a lot to work with when he
got there and a lot of people uh took
offense to that um especially when they
thought that his predecessor should
never have been fired in Jim Caldwell
I'll give you the floor on that subject
matter
Peter I
mean any coach who has three full
seasons which Matt Patricia is going to
have you know barring a them being one
and 13 or something you know in
December any coach who has three full
Seasons with a general manager who chose
him and who he is by all uh you know by
all uh people who are close to both guys
GM that that he likes and he respects
and who's building the team his way you
cannot expect to have more than three
years in today's NFL and you can't
expect to be four games into your third
year and to have won 10
games taking over a team that went nine
and seven and to have any empathy
sympathy or anybody agreeing with you oh
my God we you know we really needed uh
to do a lot of surgery when we took over
here well maybe you did and maybe there
are things the public doesn't know but
you know
what when you are 10 25 and one in three
years no one is going to have any
sympathy for you or with you over your
state at that moment and so to me Rich I
think it was uh a bad idea to say that
and not only a bad idea but he said it
at an inopportune time after his team
blew a double digit lead
again again and lost
uh to to a good team but lost a game
that they were up 14 nothing and at some
point at some point you know Matt
Patricia is going to have to realize
that when you get three years in the
NFL three full off seasons and three
seasons okay that is how coaches are
judged these days if they're fortunate
some coaches only get one ask Steve wils
how fortunate feels after getting blown
out in Arizona by you know after one
year ask the slew of coaches who get
blown out after two years three years
maybe is not enough time that you not
the time that you want but in the NFL
these days that is what is defined as
patience a threeyear
opportunity to turn a team around and
you really shouldn't be saying anything
in the middle of a month into your third
year you're 1025 and one and one and
three this year Peter King of NBC Sports
NFL Insider just a couple more minutes
left with you I'll ask you the
million-dollar question of the day is
what do the Cowboys do from here I know
that you could sit here and say you know
just play better execute better whatever
but it it certainly I forget who said it
it might have been Damen Woody uh I I
forget who said it but somebody said
last night on Twitter that it isn't
enough to Simply collect great pass
rushers okay if you do that without if
you do it myopically and don't worry
about your up the-middle defense it's
like building a great baseball team with
a shortstop second baseman and center
fielder who are lousy fielders um you
know it's obvious that the running game
the opposing running game uh has killed
the Dallas Cowboys in many instances I
mean you know no no player no defensive
player worth his salt can look at that
tape yesterday and you know giving up
300 and some yards rushing that's like
that's like uh you know if if if a if a
manager left a pitcher in to absorb an
11 run beating through four Innings and
you know look if if Mike McCarthy and
Mike Nolan could take anybody out and
put anybody in there yesterday they
certainly would have I think the bigger
question now rich is you know could mik
Nolan be in trouble it may have to be
something you know symbolically that the
that the Cowboys do I don't support
doing something like that but then again
I'm not there I'm not inside the walls
um you you have to figure out right now
urgently you know the building's on fire
and you got to do something to put the
fire out and then just a last one for
you based on this is uh Earl Thomas has
he just lost it I mean what is The
Insider scoop here that uh a potential
Hall of Fame backend Defender who wants
to play in Dallas with a Texas
background is sitting at home uh why
normally that would be the end of that
for Dallas what's going on with ear
Thomas Peter yeah I think I think the uh
you know I think the
Ravens tried to give him every break and
really wanted to keep him but Rich you
know what was really shocking to me
about the Ravens all right usually
usually it's the coaching staff or the
front office when you see a move like
that made when a when a potential Hall
of Fame player gets fired uh at a
position this excellent football team
needs you know you usually hear you know
grumblings in the front office or coach
staff whatever Rich The Players did not
want Earl Thomas the players wanted this
move to be made uh several in the player
leadership wanted this move to be made
and so that's what you have to ask
yourself now if if some
players you know at a position of great
need uh didn't want you if you were late
and I mean Mike silver reported this and
I heard it's absolutely true that um he
was very late one day because he stopped
to get his car washed on the way to on
the way to work on the way into the
Ravens I mean you know it's just what
what kind of person do do you want I'm
saying do you want that kind of person
on your team if it was a one-time
incident you shake your head roll your
eyes and say
okay you know you got to put up with
some things with great players but it
wasn't a one-time thing so it when I
hear that teams for whatever reason are
not interested in Earl Thomas I'm not
surprised Peter thanks for the time
appreciate it great stuff as always and
uh and uh let's chat again real soon
thanks again Peter all right hey Rich
all the best of you bet that's Peter
King at Peter King hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right
here